if you watch black mirrors interactive
movie Bandersnatch and wondered where
you'd seen the actor playing kahlan
before you were far from alone here's
what will poulter has been up to since
making his screen debut and where you
might have watched his work along the
way at the age of 14 Poulter played Lee
Carter the lead role in 2007 son of
Rambo directed and written by Garth
Jennings a coming-of-age story about two
young boys in their attempt to remake
the Rambo film first blood the film
premiered to positive reviews especially
for Poulter and his co-star bill Milner
you don't tell me that they're hiding
then I have no choice but to shoot you
and your cat do you have any last
requests I was just soon after Rambo
Poulter booked a television series in
England called school of comedy which
began airing in 2008 previously a youth
based sketch show based out of filter
school it premiered at the Edinburgh
Festival Fringe and was soon picked up
by e4 where it ran for two years the
better they get the kokia they get who
likes shikoku kid 2009 saw Poulter's
biggest break yet he was cast in a
featured role in the third film based on
CS Lewis's Chronicles of Narnia
Poulter's bookish and irritating
character used to scrub debuted in
2010's voyage of the Dawn Treader the
film performed well at the box office
but didn't fare as well critically with
a 50% average on Rotten Tomatoes however
some critics singled out Poulter's
performance with luke white Thompson
from me saying that Poulter's turn as
Eustace injects a welcome note of
comedic cynicism into the sea of
sentimentality
after his blockbuster year in 2010
Poulter took on a smaller project
appearing in the 2011 British
Independent Film Wild Bill directed by
Dexter Fletcher
the crime comedy tells the story of the
titular Belle who has recently been
released from prison after serving under
a vicious drug lord Poulter took on the
role of Bill's fifteen-year-old son who
has dropped out of school and is now
working on a construction site though
the film was certainly a smaller
production than The Chronicles of Narnia
it fared much better critically with a
100% fresh rating on Rotten Tomatoes in
2013 Poulter appeared and we're the
Millers a big-budget Hollywood comedy
starring Jennifer Aniston and Jason
Sudeikis Sudeikis plays a low-level pot
dealer forced to transport drugs across
the US border and into Mexico figuring
he can fly under the radar
if he looks like an average Joe he
enlists Aniston to pose as his wife and
two teenage runaways to pose as his
children Poulter plays the socially
awkward Kenny showing off his broad
comedy chops as well as his impeccable
American accent so Casey I guess it's
nice tree to get your haircut
I mean being homeless enough the film
was successful at the box office and
though critical response was tepid at
best Poulter's career was given a jump
start with many critics singling him out
as a highlight in 2014 Poulter appeared
as Gally in the film adaptation of The
Maze Runner a popular series of young
adult novels Poulter described the film
as a turning point for his career and it
was yet another blockbuster notch to add
to his belt with an excellent box-office
turnout in the United States and an even
better one abroad Poulter returned to
his role in 2018 space runner the death
cure Poulter's next project was another
indie
glass land written and directed by
Gerard Barrett the film stars Chuck
Rayner as John who must help his
troubled mother played by Toni Collette
as she struggles with severe alcoholism
Bulger plays John's friend Shane who
lives with his mother as well but who
has a much angrier and much more fraught
relationship with her last LAN premiered
to positive reviews and Poulter was once
again identified as a standout in 2015
Alejandro G and yari two followed up his
Best Picture winner Birdman with the
stark Western drama the revenant
the film which focuses on Leonardo
DiCaprio's Hugh glass struggling to
survive on the frozen frontier after
he's abandoned by his group of fellow
trappers was highly lauded earning
numerous awards and nominations and
brought in more than 530 million dollars
at the worldwide box office Poulter
played jim bridger who remains loyal to
glass even though he is repeatedly
tricked by the other trappers as they
try to leave him for dead
some critics described his part as the
most morally difficult in the entire
film and Poulter himself described the
difficult shooting experience as pushing
him to the absolute limit but in terms
of prestige it certainly paid off in
2017 polgár played sadistic policeman
Phillip Krauss and Kathryn Bigelow's
Detroit which tells the story of 1967 s
12 street riots Krauss kills a suspected
looter and spends the remainder of the
film framing innocent people for crimes
that he committed Poulter's performance
received numerous accolades and some
critics even believed he could earn an
Oscar nomination for his death
polarizing roles before ending 2018 with
a bang and Bandersnatch Poulter starred
in The Little Stranger based on Sarah
waters novel of the same name Poulter
plays a disfigured War veteran haunted
by his past the little stranger is met
with mixed reviews but considering the
accolades and blockbusters he's racked
up in such a short career already we'll
call this one a minor exception check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]